Father in Heaven again we want to thank
you for your presence here today and we
just ask for your continued presence as
we look at the test of the Prophet Lord
and we apply these tests to the gift of
Prophecy in Ellen White Lord we just ask
for your continued blessing now for
continued illumination of the holy
spirit in Jesus name we pray amen
okay now
Deuteronomy 18 verse 22 the prophecies
must come true let's look at that
Deuteronomy 18
and verse 22.
who wants to read that for me
Deuteronomy 18 and verse 22.
okay Len I don't think you've read yet
okay when a prophet speaks something and
it doesn't come to pass right
then he says don't worry about what that
Prophet said that's not a true Prophet
are you with me
Jeremiah 29.
or 28 sorry Jeremiah 28 and verse 9.
who wants to read that
okay go ahead
okay when the prophet prophesies
peace
and that word doesn't come to pass
that's saying essentially what we read
there in Deuteronomy so the message of
the prophet
must come true
now I want you to go to Jeremiah 18 with
me
and we're going to see
a an exception to that rule
Jeremiah 18.
Jeremiah 18 God is speaking to his
prophet
verse 5
. are you with me in Jeremiah 18 and
verse 5.
and the Lord says then the word of the
Lord came to me Jeremiah is saying here
saying O House of Israel
can I not do with you as this Potter
says the Lord look as the clay is in The
Potter's hands so are you in my hand oh
House of Israel the instant I speak
concerning a nation and concerning a
kingdom to pluck up to pull down and to
destroy it
if that Nation against whom I have
spoken what
turns from its evil I will what
relent of the disaster that I thought to
bring upon it
and the instant I speak concerning a
nation and concerning a kingdom to build
and to plant it if it does what
if it does evil in my sight so that it
does not obey my voice then I will
relent concerning what
the good with which I said I would
benefit it what's the Lord telling us
there
now the prophecies some prophecies may
be
conditional
God may say I'm going to do this and so
but if the situation changes he says I
may change what I'm going to do if I
prophesy destruction and the nation
turns around then I'm going to relent
from the destruction I was going to do
and if I prophesy prosperity and the
nation turns against me then they're not
going to prosper do you follow that
okay now the Lord says to us that one of
the tests of a of a true Prophet is
their prophecy must come to pass but we
know that one exception one that most
everybody knows is that of the prophet
Jonah right and it's funny because the
whole issue if you go back to Jonah the
whole issue with the prophet Jonah was
that Jonah fled
from giving the message to Nineveh of
course he was swallowed by the great
fish and spit back out on the sand and
then he decided you know what maybe I
was a little bit rash and I need to go
do what the Lord told me to do and he
went into Nineveh and he prophesied
against Nineveh but what was it that
made Jonah run in the first place does
anybody know
he was afraid that God was going to send
him
you know it's not it's not good for a
prophet's resume to prophesy something
and then have it not come to pass
and so Jonah's whole the whole essence
of why do you run and get on that ship
anyway and go the opposite direction
from Nineveh because he was afraid that
if I prophesied in Nineveh the Lord's
going to be gracious he's going to have
mercy and compassion on Nineveh they're
going to turn away they're going to turn
back to him and God's not going to
destroy them
and you know Jonah's message to Nineveh
if you read it was not it did not didn't
have a conditional element in what he
said
he said 40 days and Nineveh is going to
be overthrown he didn't say but if you
guys straighten up then God will relent
all he said is 40 days is all you all
got and then the city's dust you know
this is these ashes and dust this the
guy's gonna destroy you
but
the Lord did exactly what Jonah was
afraid of you remember when Jonah had
prophesied to Nineveh he went up on the
hillside to watch
all right I did my job now come on Lord
don't let me down
and wanted the fire to come down and
devour Nineveh only it didn't happen and
Jonah got mad and so God gives him the
little lesson with that gourd right that
plant grows over gives him a little
shade and then it dies and Jonah's all
mad
because the plant died
and he says Jonah you all mad because
the plant died and yet you want me to
destroy all of these hundreds of
thousands of people
and he I I think Jonah got the message
there but his whole fear was I'm going
to give this prophecy and then God's
going to relent from what he's going to
do and everybody's going to call me a
false prophet
would they have been right
and calling him a false prophet no
and you and I have to understand the
nature of conditional prophecies or we
might be in danger of accusing a prophet
of being a false prophet that's a true
prophet
okay because Ellen White has given
conditional prophecies but let's not
look at those right off let's look at
some fulfilled prophecies with Ellen
White does she pass this test I don't
have time to go through all these but
there's just some awesome stuff here uh
fulfilled prophecies she said in 1905
that cancer is a germ or virus which
Medical Science began to endorse only in
the 1950s
her teaching in regard to the dangers of
tobacco preceded scientific evidence
it was in the 1860s that all might said
tobacco was malignant it was
cancer-causing it wasn't until the 1950s
that the American uh
that the uh helped me out here
um the long the Surgeon General came out
with his warning against cigarette
smoking that was called will cause lung
cancer
how did she know
uh this is under Health uh prenatal
influences uh some of the things you
know some of the things Ellen White said
were directly opposed by the experts of
her day I mean they thought this one was
a loon
with some of the things that she said
and if you've had a chance to peruse
your book at all one thing that's
amazing when you go to the section on
our health message is to understand the
health practices when Ellen White
received that Health Vision
well I want to tell you something the
health in the 1860s was crazy you know
bloodletting and leeches and these types
of things you've heard about that in the
past but just all kinds of craziness
you might have read about the story with
William Miller people go to a
phrenologist you know what a
phrenologist is
somebody who asked you know what it is
yeah studies the bumps on your head to
determine your intelligence
that's what a phrenologist does
um
you know I I don't know if that's good
or bad if you should have more or less
but at any rate
um there were crazy medical practices
and so some things Ellen White said were
I mean imagine being an Adventist in
Ellen White's day having that confidence
in the gift of property is prophecy to
say you know we don't have any evidence
on this but I know because we've tested
this woman as a prophet that what she
says is true
today we have scientific evidence
we don't need any faith to believe in
what Elm white said in regard to health
anymore
um I like this quote number four
consider the following quote from Dr
Clive McKay not an Adventist former
professor of nutrition at Cornell
University in the 1950s said that Ellen
White's basic concepts about the
relationship between diet and health
have been verified to an unusual degree
by scientific advances of the past
decades
in spite of the fact that the works of
Mrs White were written long before the
Advent of modern scientific nutrition no
better overall guide is available today
Dr McKay questioned the the the how
Ellen White knew he came across one of
her books I believe councils and dies in
Foods or something read this book he
said how in the world does his woman
know what she's writing about how to
dialogue with some of our Adventist uh
um leaders
said tell me how does this woman know
what she's writing about
well they said you know they didn't want
to say she's a prophet I mean this is a
non-evidence what are you going to tell
him she said well she was a prophet
so they said well he said uh McKay said
well
or our evidence leader said well she
just uh she was very careful in what she
selected as far as you know Health
principles she just looked up different
things and she selected what was
important you know the things that were
true
and McKay this guy's a professor of
nutrition he understands healthy
understood Health from his studies in
the 1800s he says so tell me this how'd
she know what to how'd she know what to
select
there was such a there was such a
massive amount of garbage in the 1860s
how in the world does she know how what
to select
and so then as they began to dialogue
they said well we believe that she was
inspired by God he said she would have
been inspired by God to know what she
knows
um
let me see if I have it
would you like would you like a copy of
the review and Herald articles that we
asked Dr Clive McKay to write in regard
to the health message
he wrote three articles in the review
and Harold and and and explained this
whole you know just he was he was my his
it was mind-boggling to him that she
knew what she did and it's really some
uh some interesting stuff here that was
Dr Clive McKay in the area of Health
ever prophecies come true absolutely
education I'm going to kind of skip
through that there's something I'm going
to pick up on that just a little bit
further along Florence stratomire was a
was a leader in education that basically
said hey This Woman's way Advanced and
what she's writing about uh about
education
uh rise of papal influence
brothers and sisters
when when I was watching what was I
watching
oh I just saw this and I'm trying to
think where I saw it
oh I read it in a uh in one of my my son
got a book from the library and in the
um
in the in the early days of America
Rome sent over a monument or a piece of
something a stone marble for the
Washington Monument
you know what we did in America with
that stone
we dumped it in the Potomac River
because we wanted nothing to do with the
Catholic church in America
and so here in this time frame Ellen
White's saying oh yeah the Catholic
church is going to gain so much
prominence in America that all the world
is going to wander after you what do you
think that sounded like in the 1800s
and look at it today
we can take that alone
and and you've got the statement right
there from her two statements from the
book uh great controversy
without a grasp of where we came from a
Seventh-Day Adventist it's hard
sometimes to realize the weight
of evidence we have in regard to the
spirit of Prophecy when you realize how
opposed people were in America back then
in the days that she wrote these things
to Catholicism and now to see that her
prophecies have come true it was utterly
impossible back then and yet here we are
union of protestantism and Catholicism
whoo talk about protestantism gaining or
Catholicism gaining some prominence in
the in the United States that's one
thing but to say that the Protestants
would link up with them
impossible
and yet you're aware probably of the
annulment
of the Augsburg confession
I how many of you know what the Augsburg
confession is
how many of you know what the Augsburg
oh
you need to read here's a reading
assignment for you great controversy the
chapter called protest of the princes
if you don't know what the uh Augsburg
confession is you don't know what a
Protestant is
protest of the princes Protestant means
came from protest the reformed princes
of Germany protested against the
non-biblical teachings of the Catholic
church and under the in under the uh the
uh
you know from the teachings and reading
about from what Martin Luther was
preaching and these guys were taking
their stand on the positions he was the
Bible in the Bible only no more
indulgences no more the Pope's forgiving
sins and all this we don't want these
non-biblical teachings anymore we're
sticking with the Bible in the Bible
only they wanted it drafted up Martin
Luther and Philip melanthin helped draft
together the Augsburg confession which
was basically a statement of protestant
belief that they brought before Germany
and said this is where we stand as
Protestants
that's the essence of it the Augsburg
confession was the Magna Carta of the
Reformation
and in
was it 99
I've got I've got the paper with me uh
and I can tell you more detail but in
the there was a joint declaration
by the Lutheran Church and the Catholic
church that basically said we annul the
Augsburg confession it was on the
anniversary date of the Augsburg
confession and said the Protestant
Reformation was basically just a
misunderstanding
oh that's convenient
50 million plus 50 million is very
conservative estimate people died over
misunderstanding
the union of protestantism and
Catholicism that's a fulfillment of
Prophecy that happened in 1999.
I have a news release on that from I
think the Washington Post
calamities
look at what it says here under
calamities just look at the statement by
Ellen White we've looked at the news
lately
this is in messages to young people
Pages 89 and 90 also in Last Day Events
page 24 we shall see troubles on all
sides thousands of ships will be hurled
into the depths of the sea navies will
go down and human lives will be
sacrificed by the millions this was
penned before World War One this was
panned before World War II nobody had
seen such Devastation before in war
fires will break out unexpectedly and no
human effort will be able to quench them
the Palaces of the earth will be swept
away in the fury of the Flames disasters
by rail
will become more and more frequent
confusion collision and death without a
moment's warning will occur on the what
great lines of travel what were the
Great lines of travel
ship and train
and Stagecoach
how much more do we see a fulfillment of
that today
who would have known in her day an
entire plane goes down 240 people just
like that they're gone
probation has now closed for those
people
on the freeways every day on the great
lines of travel things that she didn't
even fully understand yet she penned it
out do we see a fulfillment yeah
and then she says the end is near
probation is closing these are signs for
us oh let us seek God while he may be
found and call upon him when he is near
look at this Civil War section I think
this is fascinating
months before the War Began one state
South Carolina had seceded from the
Union the military and government
leaders of our country including
President Lincoln saw the secession as
only A Minor Threat the renowned editor
of the New York Tribune Horace Greeley
wrote a few old women with broomsticks
could go down there and beat all the
Rebellion out that there is in South
Carolina
the week before he wrote If someone with
the firmness of Andrew Jackson could go
down there today and say South Carolina
where are you going they reply back into
the Union again sir
in the same week Mrs White gave a public
address in Parkville Michigan Sabbath
January 12 1861 quote men are making
light of the secession ordinance that
has been passed by South Carolina on
December 201860. they have little idea
of the trouble that is coming on our
land no one in this house has even
dreamed of the trouble that is coming
I have just been shown in Vision she
said that a number of states are going
to join South Carolina in the secession
and a terrible war will be the result in
the vision I saw large armies raised by
both the North and the South I was shown
the battle raging I heard the booming of
the Canon I saw the dead in wounded
falling on every side I was then taken
to hospitals and saw the suffering of
the sick and the wounded prisoners I was
taken in the vision to the homes of
those who lost Sons brothers or husbands
in the war there was distress and
mourning over all the Land There are men
in this house
who will lose sons in that war
you can imagine hearing a sermon like
that on Sabbath from the prophet
she was scoffed at in the meeting
newspaper reporters were outside that
were outside made Light Of Her speech
the sentiment was now we know she's not
a true prophet
this is not going to happen
some three months later 11 states has
seceded and elected their Confederate
president but President Lincoln called
for a paltry 75 000 men and for three
months to put down the Rebellion he felt
that no more were needed the rest is
history the north would have almost 3
million men on the field of battle and
the South would have half that number
the U.S lost more people in that war
than all of our other Wars combined to
this date
foreign
White's warning of the coming War and
the terrible Slaughter to follow
though they contradicted the thinking of
our country's leaders were accurate and
well-founded she was obviously getting
her information from another source
incidentally there were at least 10 men
who attended her lecture that lost sons
in that war
did the prophecies come to pass
absolutely
the rise of modern spiritualism I'm not
going to go into that
um
it basically just tells us in the days
when Ellen White wrote Her counsel about
the spiritualism and the seances and the
spirit mediums Etc
it was just beginning just a handful of
people she said this thing's going to
sweep our nation and today spiritualism
is spiritualism in in in most of what we
come in contact with
you know one of the things there's a new
movie coming out C.S Lewis is a lion
witch in the wardrobe
all the Christians are going to see it
it's the famous C.S Lewis we've got
J.R.R tolkiens the Lord of the Rings oh
the spiritual significance Star Wars oh
yeah the dark and the the the good and
the evil These Are Spiritual it's
spiritualism folks
you know what spiritualism is if you
look it up in the dictionary
does anybody know what spiritualism is
defined as
a belief that you can communicate with
the Dead
okay
does it communicate with the dead in
Star Wars
when I went to uh when I first became a
Christian I went to see the movie with
some friends I was still going to movies
I went to the movie Lion King
there's a kids movie afterwards I said I
told my friends I said that's it my
brother and I joked about I said man we
called him de's it's asking major d e's
in it there's doctrinal errors
and what are you talking about he's
talking to his dead father Mufasa he
said oh man that's it's a kid's movie
it's no big deal that's spiritualism
it's always no big deal exactly and this
is what we are so immersed in
spiritualism in our in our country today
that uh
Ellen White foretold that it would
happen
when she wrote these things down it
wasn't the case see today for you and I
to read it it's like well you know we
don't realize the import of that we
don't realize how impossible it was in
her day and yet the prophecies have come
to pass
let's go on here the the message is
number six
test number six their messages will
always lead closer to Christ Deuteronomy
13 1-4
Deuteronomy 13
4 who wants to read that for us
yes and
Sarah thank you Sarah Deuteronomy 13 1-4
pay close attention to this one
this is interesting
go ahead
or Dreamer please and give it to be a
sign or a wonder and
then
if he's based on TV saying let us go
after other gods which thou Hast not
known and let us serve them Thou shalt
not hearken unto the noise of that
Prophet or that dreamer is reading for
the Lord your God proveth you to know
whether you love the Lord your God with
all your heart and with all your soul he
shall walk after the Lord your God and
fear them and keep his Commandments and
obey his voice and ye shall serve him
unto him okay that's that's interesting
isn't it it says if the prophet
prophesies something and what
what he prophesies does what
comes true it comes to pass but in the
midst of it he says what
let's go after other gods
then you know that God hasn't sent him
so now he prophesies he speaks and it
comes to pass
you know when Jesus worked miracles I
want to tell you something
the Miracles Christ performed
didn't save anybody's Soul right
what was his purpose for performing
miracles
why did Jesus perform miracles
okay to give credibility to listen to
give credibility to the message
in one of the best tests for any
Supernatural manifestation is what's the
message that goes with it and this is
what this is saying if somebody comes
and they may show signs and wonders they
may prophesy something and it comes to
pass wow look at that but if in the
midst of it
they're saying now this is the evidence
that we need to come and follow other
gods if it's going to lead you away from
the word of God what do you know to do
stay shun that shun that that profit
that vision is not from the Lord
what they're saying is not from the Lord
which would give us the converse which
I've put here
a true Prophet will always lead closer
to Christ not lead away
their message isn't saying hey come and
follow you know here's the here's the
signs of Wonder now come follow and go
after other gods no the purpose of the
true Prophet is to draw people closer to
the Lord
if a supposed Prophet does not draw
people closer to Christ they're not a
prophet
if they do
they've passed that test an important
test of the gift of Prophecy and to me
this is a this is one of the most
important tests he won't argue with
Ellen White well I don't think she's a
true Prophet uh let's see you're the
devil and you're going to employ a false
prophet and dog on it she keeps leading
people to Jesus
when you go
you know how many people have been led
to the Lord through Ellen White's
Ministry
I mean if I was the devil I'd get a new
false prophet wouldn't you
seriously now listen look at what it
says here in the book
from the book Seventh-day Adventist
believe and also from Herbert Douglas is
a messenger of the lord it's true isn't
it
let's look at in Andrews University
study a comparison was done on the
attitude and behavior of Adventists who
regularly read Ellen White's books with
those who don't okay it's a good study
it's just within the Adventist Church
and is focusing on the Adventists who do
read Spirit of Prophecy and Adventists
who say oh I don't know I don't like to
read them they're too discouraging and
this that and the other look at the
effect it has on people
the founding conclusion was reached
quote readers have a closer relationship
with Christ
more certainty of their standing with
God I put that in their assurance
well people tell me oh no Illinois takes
away the Assurance of Salvation
apparently not
the people who more regularly read
Spirit of Prophecy have more Assurance
of Salvation they have a closer
relationship with Christ they're more
likely to have identified their
spiritual gifts
they are more in favor of spending for
public evangelism then
that's what we need right there
Ben's a church member of mine in
Hastings I'll tell you brothers and
sisters it's amazing to sit in church
boards and I oh we don't have any money
left over for evangelism because we got
to pay for the lights and the carpet and
everything uh pardon me what do we exist
for
to keep this building in shape
those who read regularly the the
messages from Ellen White are more
likely to have I'm sorry more in favor
of spending for public evangelism and
contribute more heavily to local
missionary projects they feel more
prepared for witnessing and actually
engage in more witnessing and Outreach
programs
they are more likely to study the Bible
daily to pray for specific people to
meet in Fellowship groups and to have
Daily Family Worship they see their
church more positively they are
responsible for winning more converts
man we need more members reading the
spirit of Prophecy that's what I'm going
to say and go on
from the book messenger of the Lord that
you have there
uh he comments on this study and he
States also that 82 percent of the
readers usually are always have daily
personal Bible study while only 47
percent of the non-readers do
do they lead people closer to Jesus it
would sure appear so wouldn't it
okay number seven
they will plainly point out sin
um Isaiah 58 1-2
we'll go to Lamentations 214 Isaiah 58 1
uh
this is where the Lord says
um lift up the trumpet
and show my people their transgressions
in the house of Israel or the house of
Jacob their sins right
God speaks to the prophet Isaiah says
point out by the sins of my people
but Lamentations too kind of fleshes
this out a little bit more
I really like the way this reads
Lamentations 2 verse 14.
Lamentations who has three Lamentations
214. Ben what do you got there what are
you reading from
me okay the King James uh I think is the
is the language that really I think well
reading in the new King James first and
then we'll read it in a
King James
the prophet says scene for you false and
deceptive Visions they have not
uncovered your iniquity to bring to
bring back your captives but have
envisioned for you false prophecies and
delusions
okay
now I want he's going to read it in the
King James version and listen to what it
says I want you to get the sense of what
the Bible is saying here
in the book of Lamentations
Prophets seen Vain and foolish things
for thee okay pause thy prophets have
seen Vain and foolish things for thee
what kind of prophets are they
okay the Bible already identifies them
they're false prophets look at the
characteristic they've seen Vain and
foolish things and gone
and they have not discovered discovered
that iniquity okay they've not
discovered thine iniquity and you have
different translations there what what
do they say
they've not discovered they've not
uncovered your sin they've not exposed
your sin are you with me on that
okay
they've not discovered thine iniquity
listen to the next part to turn away thy
captivity to turn away thy captivity let
me ask you something what was the
condition of God's people in the days of
Jeremiah when he wrote the book of
Lamentations
where were they
were captives in Babylon okay
and Jeremiah writes the Lamentations
then he says these false prophets
let me ask you this question why did God
let go why did God let them go captive
into Babylon
because of their sin because they were
turned away from God
if a true Prophet cared about the people
if God cared about his people what would
he do
he'd tell them about the thing that's
keeping them away from him
bringing all the trouble on them but
notice what it says here the false
prophets have not discovered your
iniquity
to turn away your captivity but listen
to the next part
okay but have seen for the false burdens
and causes of banishment what does that
mean a cause of banishment
what's a Cause
the reason
banishment to wear
Babylon
and so notice what he's saying God is
saying these false prophets they're not
willing to show you your sin
so that you can get rid of it and turn
back to me
they're coming up with other reasons
that you're in Babylon false they're
coming up with false reasons for
banishment Oh no you're not doing
anything wrong we're all doing well
we're all doing exactly what God wants
us to do it's not anything that we've
done that we're here in Babylon that
Jeremiah's crazy he's sitting here
telling us about our iniquity God loves
us God doesn't care about all that
business and and Jeremiah's just trying
to Jeremiah's just trying to discourage
us all
it sounds exactly like today doesn't it
why does God point out our sin
to discover our iniquity
to turn away our captivity
God doesn't want us to be captives God
wants us to be free God wants us to have
freedom in Christ we're not going to
have it with sin while we're holding on
and cleaning Us in so the prophet's job
is to point us to where we're airing
for the purpose of bringing us back
tonight is it always comfortable to be
told where you're airing no and that's
why the false prophets were so popular
but the purpose of the Lord in pointing
out sin
is to draw his people back and he said
that's a characteristic of the true
Prophet not of the false look at what
the statement says there in faith I live
by Page 293.
Ellen White said there are those who
will be glad to lull you to sleep in
your carnal security but I have a
different work
my message is to alarm you
to bid you reform your lives and cease
your Rebellion against the god of the
universe take the word of God and see if
you are in harmony with it once again
what's the prophet doing pointing you
back to the word and saying you need
examine are you living in accordance
with the word she doesn't take herself
as the standard does she
take the word of God see if you're in
harmony with it is your character such
as will bear the search of the in
Heavenly of the Heavenly investigation
if you're not ready for heaven do you
want to know now or do you want to know
when Jesus comes
amen
and that's why God sends the prophet
that's one of the roles that we we've
looked at and here it says that's a test
of the Prophet The Prophet doesn't point
out sin is not a prophet that God has
called
test number eight
they have absolutely no association with
spiritualism let's go to Deuteronomy 18
Again who wants to read for me
Deuteronomy 18 10 to 12. somebody who
hasn't read yet
Deuteronomy 18 10 to 12. Royce you
haven't read yet have you
no all right Deuteronomy 18.
10 through 12.
there shall not be found among you
anyone who makes his son or his daughter
passed through the fire or who practices
witchcraft
Sayers or one who interprets
or or a sorcerer
or one who conjures spells or a medium
or a spiritist or one who calls up the
dead for all who does that these things
aren't are an Abomination to the Lord
and because of these Abominations the
Lord your God drives them out before you
now the King James brings up something
in verse 11. I'll give this back to you
in a minute
in verse 11 and King James says
or a charmer
or a consaulter with familiar spirits it
says Spirit medium in the new King James
what's a familiar spirit
it's a spirit you're familiar with
okay that's what it is so I like that
reading it just it just helps us know
when it's talking about a medium that's
what it's talking about people who
profess to claim that they communicate
with the spirit world people that you're
familiar with oh I can conjure up Uncle
Phil for you and he can talk to you you
can carry on this conversation and
everything else
the Bible says that these people were
banished from the land god forbade this
kind of
um
communication with the spirit world or
or all of these aspects of spiritualism
so a prophet quote unquote who claims to
use crystal balls and Tarot cards and
all this other business
is not a prophet
that's not news to most of you
and yet again there are people oh Gene
Dixon you know or something else
but but we we have today we have things
like the Harry Potter deal where people
say yeah but at least it's making my
kids read at least my kids are
interested in Reading you know
um
yeah okay why don't I get a scripture
will you kids replay boy maybe I'll get
them that is that interesting to read
will you kids look at it
it's probably safer than spiritualism
I'm telling you brothers and sisters I'm
not recommending the other but you know
we do we downplay that oh Harry Potter
it makes my kids read
it's spiritualism
you know the devil's going to use this
we're told that there are two major
Avenues of deception in the last days
number one is Sunday sacredness what's
the other one
spiritualism
these are the two major deceptions of
the devil at the end of time you know
and yeah well my kid likes to read it's
they're getting used to this they're
they're settling into this understanding
and what do you think is going to happen
when they see the powerful physical
manifestations of the devil in
spiritualism
Ellen White says there are many of us
who will come face to face with loved
ones who've passed on in death
sound like them look like them
every emotion in your body is going to
be scream at you like this is grandma or
this is my cousin that I died you know
when we were you know
I'm telling you it's an overpowering
deception
and uh the Lord forbids any kind of
communication like that any kind of
association with spiritualism
and
what does Ellen White say about it you
read the statement there uh let's go
halfway down I'm not going to read the
whole thing
um halfway down the paragraph it says
the claim that men can hold
communication with evil spirits is
regarded as a fable of the Dark Ages but
spiritualism which numbers its converts
by hundreds of thousands Yea by millions
that was when this was written in 18 uh
yay by millions which has made its way
into scientific circles which has
invaded churches and has found its favor
in legislative bodies and even in the
courts of Kings
you remember when Nancy Reagan was
communicating with uh
Eleanor Roosevelt wasn't it
seriously
you know nobody you know okay first
first lady is communicating with the the
dead Spirit of Eleanor Roosevelt
and even in the courts of Kings this
Mammoth deception is but a Revival and a
new disguise of the Witchcraft condemned
and prohibited of old
to me that right there spells out she's
a true prophet
I mean there are pastors won't even
preach on that in other churches praise
the Lord for a prophet who's clarified
this issue for you and I
so they have no absolutely a true
Prophet will not con use crystal balls
or tarot cards or any of this other
business and be involved in any kind of
spiritualism
and number nine they will bear the
fruits of righteousness uh numbers
Matthew 7 21 and without going there I
think you're familiar with it that's one
of several places where Jesus says you
will know them by their fruits
um
what did he say a thornbush doesn't bear
figs in a
thistle tree doesn't bear what do you
anyway I'm I'm lost at the uh specifics
right now uh but basically you know a
tree by its fruit
and a true prophet
a true Prophet is going to have
fruit evidence in the way they live
that they're a true follower of Christ
amen
you you are you with me on that let's
look at some of these here statements
this is I'm going to skip the first one
there just because there are some better
ones and I'm just looking for sake of
time I want to get through here
um these are all different
statements from non-advinists about
Ellen White the first one was her
obituary in the New York independent but
we're going to go to letter b
Ellen White had spoken
before a live audience which she did
many times Ellen White would go into the
cities this is from the Detroit press he
spoke in Detroit
to a large con audience that was made up
of anybody who wanted to come
this news reporter comes to this uh
meeting
and uh I don't know that the man was a
Christian
but he clearly was not a Seventh-Day
evidence he says this a Detroit post
reporter described observing one of Mrs
White's sermons as remarkable and
thrilling experience he says quote
although her eloquence and persuasive
Powers were well known by the audience
still they were unprepared
obviously well known by the Adventist
portion of the audience there still they
were unprepared for the powerful and
unanswerable appeal which she made she
seemed indeed almost what
inspired brothers and sisters if a
non-advinist can call her almost
inspired can't we call her inspired
he listens to her speaking he says this
woman seemed almost inspired as she
employed Sinners implored Sinners to
flee from their sins the effect of her
magnetic speech and manner was most
remarkable
the next one is from Walter Martin's
book you know who Walter Martin is wrote
the book Kingdom of the Cults wrote a
book called The Truth About Seventh-Day
Adventists in which he set forth so
graciously that he didn't view any more
that The Seventh-Day Adventists were
cult but that didn't mean he had agreed
with what we taught
and in the midst now figure this this is
a man who he's not a Seventh-Day
Adventist he really isn't favorable to
Seventh-Day Adventists he basically says
well their Christian group but I really
think they're whacked out on a couple
ideas and he's as he's setting forth the
things he disagrees with
it says he wrote after reading the
publications of The Seventh-Day
Adventist denomination in almost all the
writings of Ellen G white including her
testimonies
the writer believes that Mrs White was a
was truly a regenerate Christian woman
that just means a born-again Christian
who loved the Lord Jesus Christ and
dedicated herself unstintingly to the
task of bearing witness for him as she
felt led
then he goes on and lists some areas of
his disagreement with her teaching
that he believed were an error and in
that context says but no one can dispute
the fact that her writings conform to
the basic principles of the historic
gospel for they most certainly do
and about a paragraph later he added all
that she wrote on such subjects of
Salvation or Christian Living
characterizes her as a Christian in
every sense of the term now when the
enemies of the faith can say that about
you you are bearing the fruits of
righteousness I mean that's incredible
look at this next one I talked about
Florence stratomire and this is what I
want to get to Dr Raymond Moore what
worked for it says here well he was
working for
um he attended the American Association
of colleges let's see where was he with
at the time
uh Department of Education and
psychology at Potomac University okay
and he and some Associates went out to
this teacher's meeting secular meeting
uh
for Teacher education at the Hilton
Hotel in Chicago they were visiting with
Dr Florence stratomire an imminent
educational author and researcher
she is perhaps one of the most
distinguished women Educators in the
United States today he wrote at the time
I identified myself as a Seventh-Day
Adventist and told them a little about
our educational program she said oh I've
just been reading your book education it
was given to me by Dr Wesley Rose at
Union College then she added that as an
amazing book she continued to speak of
it describing it as a wonderful book
after I told her something about Mrs
White in what little education she had
Dr Stoudemire said well she was a
prophet wasn't she
I told her that we were careful how he
used the word Prophet but by Bible
standards she would be called one Dr
stratomire made the statement she must
have been a prophet
now Florence stratomire can say she must
have been a prophet from Reading one
little book education
certainly you and I can say with
confidence she must have been a prophet
since the other men recognized Dr
stratter Meyer as an authority in the
field of Education they immediately
began to ask for copies of the book
Dr Raymond Moore he shares that Vince
ramek I'm going to skip that because I
just read to you that's a little of the
statement that I read but I'm going to
give you the whole articles on him and
then this last one I think is powerful
the following testimony for Patriarchs
and Prophets from Mrs from Mr a.s Hinton
a member of an old southern family of
what
tobacco manufacturers in Tennessee
was sent to Ernest Lloyd by Professor
H.H Hamilton so this old tobacco uh
manufacturer writes this sends in this
quote this this testimony about the book
Patriarchs and Prophets he says this is
the most beautiful book I have ever read
and I have been reading books since I
was a child
as a literary production it is
fascinating interesting and gorgeous
as an expression of faith it is beyond
caval or criticism
it is about greatness it is inspired if
such can be said in these latter days
it has engaged my attention for a full
week and it is to me labor well bestowed
I am I surely am under obligation to my
kind friend Mrs Thompson for the loan of
This Magnificent book it almost
persuades me to be a Christian
the man was not even a Christian
and reads the book
and says this book has got to be
inspired
certainly
if a tobacco manufacturer who is not a
Christian can say the writings of Ellen
White are inspired certainly you and I
can say with confidence that Ellen White
is inspired of God he goes on to say
how far above the bickerings of
denominational sex is the effort of this
good woman it is a plea for no Doctrine
or Creed but an appeal for faith in God
in all the trials and circumstances of
of our fitful and uncertain life would
that everybody could read and reflect on
this wonderful work
and says professor H Hamilton now living
in La Sierra California writes that it
was his aunt Mrs Thompson who gave Mr
Hinton the book to read all this
happened years ago it is good to know
that Mr Hinton did slip into the church
after giving himself to the Lord and
soon afterward he passed away
he stepped into the church you all that
almost persuaded me to become a
Christian and he did become a Christian
because of this false prophet Ellen
White
have mercy
and the last the last test of a prophet
which I think is a very important test
that needs very little comment
they will not be popular Luke 6 26
somebody find that one for me who wants
to read Luke 6 26 this will be our last
text
Matthew Mark Luke 6 26 okay Mark now pay
attention to this one this is this is so
important for us to understand
let's just read Luke 6 26
Luke 6 26.
well one to you when all men shall speak
well of you for so did their fathers to
the false prophets who so do their
fathers to The Who false prophets when
all men speak well of you that's just
like the
false prophets not like the what
true Prophets
so we say I don't understand we get on
the internet there's all this stuff
about Ellen White I say praise the Lord
amen why because it's in evidence didn't
the Bible say the dragon is wrath with a
woman
the dragon's enraged with a woman he's
enraged with the church that has the
testimony of the the uh keeps the all
the Commandments of God and has the
testimony of Jesus Christ the gift of
Prophecy
brothers and sisters if we didn't have
all the opposition on the website and
stuff about our church we probably
wouldn't have a true prophet
we wouldn't fit all the tests
the fact that it's unpopular that's all
the more evidence that you and I should
hey this must be the true thing this
must be the genuine because everybody
spoke well of the false prophets
people didn't speak well the true
Prophets
you with me on that amen those are our
tests of the gift of Prophecy as Ellen
might pass the test
obviously we can spend more time there
are other things than you have in your
experience and you will continue as you
read through the writings of Ellen White
but I think we've got more than enough
evidence you know a lot of people when
they do this test of the Prophet they
might give you four tests we've looked
at ten
she passed everyone with flying colors
we should have no question
with the ministry of Ellen White that
she is indeed a true prophet
so we're gonna we're gonna finish up on
that I'm gonna have a word of Prayer
when we come back this afternoon we're
going to talk about
a little bit about how inspiration works
the mechanics of inspiration
and
um
that's it what three o'clock 3 30. okay
so after you eat now you're not going to
overeat so you're sleeping class right
you're going to get if you need a cat
nap you're going to take one right
you're going to be all rejuvenated and
ready to go at 3 30 right
now some of you are laughing at me I
I hope that doesn't mean you're going to
come in here and snooze right
because I told you the other day I'll
make an example out of you if I have to
all right let's bow our heads for a word
of closing prayer
Father in heaven
oh Father I want to thank you so much
for the gift of Prophecy that you've
given to this church
father even now as I pray and with some
of the things we've looked at and with
some of the questions I've asked I know
Lord that
none of us here have the weight of
experience of those who pass through the
early Advent movement
and father if we can just go back and
meditate and see how far you have
brought this movement
oh Father it's a miracle
and that Miracle could not have taken
place without the guiding role of the
Prophet that you've given us Church in
these last days
father my desire is that these students
would have
a firm confidence in the gift of
Prophecy that they would see from the
teachings of your word that we can't
believe the Bible and not believe in the
gift of Prophecy in these last days
father this is my desire but I can only
teach in with limited with my limited
understanding and my limited human words
and all my all my
weaknesses but father I pray your Holy
Spirit
would illuminate our minds and our
hearts so that these truths would take a
firm hold
father I pray now for the time that we
have for break and for recreation that
you would rejuvenate each and every one
of the students so that when we come
back together Lord our minds are ready
to go they're fresh and uh ready to
learn more about this wonderful gift of
Prophecy and father I thank you and I
Praise You In Jesus Name
amen